DON’T KNOW WHAT YOU’RE TALKING
ABOUT HE WAS DISINGENUOUS.
BRIAN: LYING.
STEVE: LET’S BRING IN IN BEN
DOMINIC.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
SAYS 5% IS PROBABLY THE POINT AT
WHICH YOU LOSE THE SCHOOLS,
WHAT’S GOING ON HERE?
BEN: WHAT’S GOING ON IS IN THE
AFTERMATH OF 2020 ELECTION THE
NEWS MEDIA IS WAKING UP TO THE
FACT THAT ANDREW CUOMO COVERS UP
HIS INCOMPETENCE WITH BLUSTER.
HE GETS AGGRESSIVE AND ANGRY AS
OPPOSED TO RESPONDING TO WHAT I
AGREE WAS JUST VERY
STRAIGHT-FORWARD QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN.
YOU LOOK OVER ACROSS THE
ATLANTIC AND YOU SEE IN FRANCE
AND GERMANY, THEY ARE
EXPERIENCING SIGNIFICANT SPIKES
RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE LOCKING DOWN A LOT OF
THINGS.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY AREN’T
LOCKING DOWN AND CLOSING,
SCHOOLS, THAT’S BECAUSE WE HAVE
ALL TYPES OF RESEARCH THAT WE
DIDN’T HAVE LAST SPRING AND
SUMMER ABOUT THE FACT THAT
SCHOOLS ARE NOT A SOURCE OF
MAJOR SPREAD OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
THAT’S SOMETHING THAT IS A GOOD
THING AND IT’S SOMETHING THAT
TEACHERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO AND PARTICIPANTS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO
WITH OPTIMISM AND HOPE, INSTEAD
WHAT WE ARE LEARNING IS ONE OF
THE EXCEPTIONAL THINGS ABOUT
AMERICA UNFORTUNATELY IS THE
POWER OF THESE TEACHERS UNIONS
POLITICALLY TO GET WHAT THEY
WANT OUT OF THESE SCENARIOS AS
OPPOSED TO PUTTING KIDS FIRST
AND THE PROSPECT I HAVE TO SAY
OF KIDS LOSING AN ENTIRE YEAR OF
SCHOOLING TO THIS TYPE OF FALSE
TEACHING OF THIS -- OF THIS
BLENDED LEARNING AND THE LIKE IS
REALLY ENORMOUS CONCERN NOT JUST
TO ME BUT I THINK TO ALL
AMERICANS ABOUT THE FUTURE THAT
THESE KIDS ARE GOING TO HAVE IF
WE DON’T TURN THINGS AROUND.
AINSLEY: BEN, I WANT TO PUT ONE
MORE SOUND BITE ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR BLAMING ALL NEW
YORKERS.
LISTEN.
GOVERNOR: SOCIALLY DISTANCE AND
YOU WEAR A MASK AND YOU WERE
SMART, NONE OF THIS WOULD BE A
PROBLEM.
IT’S ALL SELF-IMPOSED.
IF YOU DIDN’T EAT THE
CHEESECAKE, YOU WOULDN’T HAVE A
WEIGHT PROBLEM.
AINSLEY: BEN, YOUR REACTION.
BEN: SELF-IMPOSED WHEN ANDREW
CUOMO PAID DECISION TO PUT
PEOPLE IN NURSING HOMES.
THAT WASN’T SELF-IMPOSED.
IT WAS GOVERNMENT.
IT’S NOT SOMETHING THAT’S
SELF-IMPOSED.
THE KIDS DIDN’T EAT THE
CHEESECAKE.
THE RESPONSIBILITY REALLY IS
HIS.
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING TO OUR
POLITICAL LEADERS IN THIS MOMENT
FOR RESPONSIBLE LEADERSHIP, NOT
BLUSTER, NOT HIDING FROM THE
ACTUAL CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR
DECISIONS, INSTEAD SAYING, HEY,
WE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT THIS, ONE
THING THAT WE HAVE LEARNED IS
THAT SCHOOLS CAN BE OPEN AND
THAT WE CAN DEAL WITH THIS IN
MINIMIZING THE RISK TO CHILDREN
AND ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT
APPROACHES THAT AVOID THEM
HAVING THE LEVEL OF FEARS THAT
WE HAD BEFORE WE KNEW AS MUCH AS
WE KNOW NOW ABOUT THE VIRUS.
BRIAN: LIKE EVERY COLUMNIST TO
KEEP SCHOOLS OPEN.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" STORY THEY
WRITE TODAY, THE KIDS NEED TO BE
SOCIALIZED, 1 IN 8 KIDS IS
LIVING WITH A PARENT WITH
ADDICTION AND SCHOOL IS A REFUGE
AND OFTEN THE ONLY MEAL THEY
GET.
THEY NEED THE SOCIALIZATION AT A
YOUNG AGE AND MCKENZIE AND
COMPANY, THEY PREDICT 1 MILLION
KIDS WILL DROP OUT OF SCHOOL
BECAUSE OF PROLONGED REMOTE
LEARNING.
IT’S UNBELIEVABLE THAT HE WOULD
BLAME US FOR A WORLDWIDE
PANDEMIC THAT HAS BROUGHT TO ITS
KNEES 170 PLUS COUNTRIES AND HE
SAYS NEW YORKERS AREN’T WORTHY
OF HIM.
THE ARROGANCE OF A GUY THAT
MISSED 17 MEETINGS OF
CORONAVIRUS AND TO SIT THERE AND
SAY WE ARE NOT WORTHYY OF HIM,
BEN, I CAN’T OVERSTATE HOW THE
LACK OF SELF-AWARENESS AND EGO
OUT OF CONTROL, HE’S EMBLEMATIC
OF THAT.
BEN: HE’S GOTTEN AWAY TO IT TO
THIS POINT BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE
CHRIS SAVED ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS RIGHT ABOUT
SOMETHING, EVERYTHING WAS
GETTING THROUGH CONTEXT OF
GETTING THROUGH THE ELECTION IN
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE MEDIA.
WE ARE FINALLY HEARING THE TRUTH
WHICH IS THAT, YES, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT MAKES US FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE AT "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" TO AGREE WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP ABOUT SOMETHING BUT HE WAS
RIGHT ABOUT THIS JUST AS ALL THE
OTHER PEOPLE PUSHING FOR SCHOOLS
TO REOPEN WERE RIGHT ABOUT THIS.
CUOMO IS NOT GOING TO GET AWAY
WITH THIS CONTINUED
BLAME-SHIFTING, HE’S GOTTEN AWAY
FOR IT.
BRIAN: HE’S SELLING A BOOK EVERY
DAY.
BEN: IT IS PATHETIC.
IT IS RIDICULOUS AND KEEP IN
MIND, HE’S ABOUT TO GET A
25,000-DOLLAR RAISE, SO ONE OF
THE SITUATIONS WHERE THIS IS THE
WORST KIND OF LEADERSHIP THAT WE
COULD HAVE IN THIS MOMENT.
IT’S UNSERIOUS, IT’S WRONG, IT’S
MAKINGS DECISIONS NOT BASED ON
SCIENCE BUT BASED ON BLUSTERY
ATTITUDE AND I HOPE THAT PEOPLE
ARE ACTUALLY WAKING UP TO IT
THAT NEW YORKERS WILL RESPOND TO
IT AND PUSH BACK AGAINST TO THE
POINT WHERE --
BRIAN: MAYBE HE SHOULD TELL HIS
BROTHER TO WEAR A MASK BECAUSE
HE FORGOT TO WEAR IT FOR 7
MONTHS.
STEVE: WE DISCOVERED THE
HYPOCRISY OF HIM GOING TO THAT
FANCY BIRTHDAY DINNER FOR A
LOBBYIST WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION, THE CMA AND
NOT ONLY WAS THE LOBBYIST THERE
BUT APPARENTLY THE CEO OF THE
CMA DUSTIN CORKER WAS THERE AND
THEY SAID THEY FOLLOWED THE
STATE AND LOCAL GUIDELINES AND
YOU LOOK AT THIS STUFF, WAIT,
THEY ARE TELLING US WE CAN’T
LEAVE OUR HOUSE, WE HAVE TO WEAR
A MASK AND SHOULDN’T TRAVEL AND
THINGS LIKE THAT BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK FOR LEADERSHIP ON PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY, IT DOESN’T SEEM
YOU CAN LOOK TO THE GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA WHO SAID A COUPLE OF
DAYS AGO, YEAH, I BLEW IT AND
YOU CAN’T LOOK TO THE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION EITHER BECAUSE THEIR
TOP GUY WAS SITTING 4-INCHES
FROM SOMEBODY ON HIS LEFT AND
SOMEBODY ON HIS RIGHT.
BEN: YOU KNOW, I LOOK AT THE
PICTURE AND TO ME THAT LOOKS
LIKE A NICE THANKSGIVING DINNER.
STEVE: IT DOES, WHICH WE CAN’T
HAVE.
BEN: HE’S NOT ALLOWING
CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE.
IT’S THE TYPE OF, LOOK, THIS IS
THANKSGIVING THE HOLIDAYS, THESE
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT TO A LOT OF
AMERICANS.
IT’S A TIME WHEN WE CAN BE
GRATEFUL EVEN AFTER TIMES OF
GREAT AND TERRIBLE CHALLENGE.
THAT WAS THE CONTEXT OF THE
FIRST THANKSGIVING WHICH WE HAD
FEDERALIST ON A SERIES RUNNING
ABOUT IN 2016 PROJECT ABOUT
PILGRIMS AND LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THEM.
IN THIS CASE GAVIN NEWSOM’S
HYPOCRISY, I APPRECIATE THE
WOMAN WHO TOOK THE PICTURES.
WITHOUT THE PICTURES HE WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN AWAY WITH SPINNING
THIS AND PRETENDING LIKE HE
DIDN’T DO ANYTHING WRONG.
THE FACT THAT WE HAD SOMEONE
RECOGNIZE THE GOVERNOR AND SAY,
THAT DOESN’T LOOK RIGHT AND
SNAPPED A COUPLE OF THE PICTURES
THAT WE CAN LOOK AT THANKS TO
COLLEAGUES RIGHT THERE AT FOX
LA, THAT TO ME IS THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF HYPOCRISY AND SHOULD BE
CALLED OUT.
BRIAN: GETS WORSE.
HE LIED IN HIS APOLOGY, HE SAID
IT WAS AN OUTDOOR EVENT.
THEY DON’T HANG CHANDELIERS FROM
TREES.
BEN: DO I WANT TO SAY ONE WORD,
MY SYMPATHY GOES OUT TO THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK HARD AND ALL
RESTAURANTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THAT HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH THE
CHALLENGES.
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
SMASHED BY THIS AS YOU ALL KNOW.
FOR HIM TO SHIFT THE BLAME OR TO
PRETEND THIS WAS NO BIG DEAL OR
THAT --
>> STEVE: FOLLOWED GUIDELINES.
BEN: THIS IS THE SITUATION THAT
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE, THE
KIND OF MEAL THAT GAVIN NEWSOM
HAD.
BRIAN: $450 FOR DINNER.
[LAUGHTER]
BEN: ABSOLUTELY.
AINSLEY: I THINK WHAT PEOPLE
WERE UPSET WAS IS JUST --